This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Some years ago, I got a talking with an investor. By his own account, he was a 1%er. Like many other successful Americans before him, he had overcome many challenges growing up. And then he told me about the one thing in his life that made him sad. His kids.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。几年前，我和一位投资者交谈。据他自己说，他是那1%的精英。像他之前许多成功的美国人一样，他在成长过程中克服了许多挑战。然后他告诉我他生活中唯一让他感到难过的事情。他的孩子们。
They were sweet and smart, but they lacked drive. They had led easy lives, he told me. They didn't have the same hunger that had made him successful. I've heard variations of the same story over the years. People who have come through adversity will invariably tell you that their adversity played a central role in their success. You're the Godfather of technology. You founded this company, you're still thriving, and you came from such humble beginnings. Tell me how you did.
他们很可爱也很聪明，但缺乏动力。他告诉我，他们过着优越的生活。他们没有那种让他成功的饥饿感。多年来，我听过这个故事的各种版本。那些经历过逆境的人总是会告诉你，他们的逆境在他们的成功中发挥了核心作用。你是科技界的教父。你创立了这家公司，你依然蒸蒸日上，而你出身卑微。告诉我你是怎么做到的。
Well, I think for my favorite line is I had all the disadvantages necessary for success. I was jobless, alone parent, and as poor as it is possible to be in modern Britain without being homeless. I now know from interviewing over 50,000 people over the years, and my own personal experiences, that everything that has happened to you can be used to strengthen you if you're open to it. This idea that hard times make us stronger has been touted so often and by so many people that we rarely stop to ask ourselves, is explore whether adversity is the secret sauce of success.
嗯，我想我最喜欢的一句话是：我拥有成功所需的所有劣势。我失业了，是单亲家长，在现代英国，除了无家可归，我穷到了极致。多年来采访了超过5万人，加上我自己的个人经历，我现在知道，只要你愿意，发生在你身上的一切都可以用来增强你的力量。这种“苦难使我们更强大”的观点被如此多的人如此频繁地宣扬，以至于我们很少停下来问自己，去探索逆境是否真的是成功的秘诀。
Iranda Jaya Vikrama grew up in Sri Lanka while a civil war raged in that country. When he was 21, he moved to the United States to study. Soon after his arrival, Iran began to notice that Americans had a way of thinking about adversity and suffering that was new to him. It became the start of a lifelong exploration. Today, as a psychologist at Wake Forest University, Iran is asking a question that is increasingly relevant in many parts of the world. What happens to people as they go through terrible times and what advice can science give them about the best path forward? Iranda Jaiwakrama, welcome to Hidden Brain.
Iranda Jaya Vikrama在斯里兰卡内战期间长大。21岁时，他移居美国求学。抵达后不久，Iran开始注意到美国人有一种他从未见过的新方式来思考逆境和苦难。这成为了一场终身探索的开始。今天，作为维克森林大学的心理学家，Iran正在提出一个在世界许多地方日益相关的问题。当人们经历可怕的时刻时，他们会发生什么？科学能给他们什么关于前进的最佳路径的建议？Iranda Jaiwakrama，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。
Thank you so much for having me. Iranda, you arrived in the United States shortly before the 9-11 attacks and a few weeks after the attacks, New York's mayor Rudy Giuliani gave a speech at the United Nations. This massive attack was intended to break our spirit. Has not done that. It's made us stronger, more determined and more resolved. So there was a theme in speeches like this that jumped out at your under.
非常感谢邀请我。Iranda，你在9·11袭击前不久抵达美国，袭击发生几周后，纽约市长鲁迪·朱利安尼在联合国发表了演讲。这次大规模袭击旨在摧毁我们的精神。但它没有做到。它使我们更强大、更坚定、更有决心。所以像这样的演讲中有一个主题让你印象深刻。
You felt it reflected a particularly American way of thinking about trauma. What did you hear? One thing that I remember being struck by was this idea that, well, this bad thing has happened, but something good is gonna come out of it, right? That if we're absolutely determined, that something good is gonna come out of it.
你觉得这反映了一种特别的美国式创伤思维。你听到了什么？我记得印象深刻的一点是这种想法：好吧，这件坏事发生了，但会有好事从中产生，对吧？如果我们绝对坚定，就会有好事从中产生。
And I remember thinking, well, that's interesting because the first thing you typically want to do is make sure you can manage with the impact of that bad thing. And maybe in the wake of what's happened, try and return to where you were before or return to a baseline. But this is something different. This is the idea that this terrible thing has happened. But somehow we're going to overcome it and we're going to get to a place that's somehow better than before. And I'm wondering if you can almost summarize this way of thinking in a single line that you see all over social media nowadays
我记得当时想，嗯，这很有趣，因为你通常首先想做的是确保你能应对那件坏事的影响。也许在事情发生后，尝试回到你之前的位置或回到基准线。但这不同。这是那种认为“这件可怕的事情发生了，但不知何故我们将克服它，我们将到达一个比以前更好的地方”的想法。我想知道你是否能用当今社交媒体上随处可见的一句话来总结这种思维方式。
What doesn't kill you makes you stronger? Exactly and this happened I think you know in the last 10 or 15 years or so right this this quote right which comes from Friedrich Nietzsche the German philosopher It's become almost like a culture of touch, Tony. And I remember, I think in the last few years, there have been songs by Kanye West, then Klee Klopzer. What doesn't kill you makes you stronger than a little power? That that don't kill me can only make me stronger.
“杀不死你的会让你更强大”？没错，我认为这发生在过去10到15年左右，对吧？这句引言来自德国哲学家弗里德里希·尼采。它几乎成了某种文化口头禅。我记得，过去几年里，Kanye West和Kelly Clarkson都有过这样的歌。“杀不死你的会让你更强大，不是吗？”“杀不死我的只会让我更强大。”
There have been memes that go around the internet. Life and man said, what doesn't kill me. Just makes me stronger. Since almost like a default attitude towards trauma, right? Like when bad things happen, we're going to use this as an opportunity to become better. And that, to me, seems quintessentially American, right? The idea that we are going to take even the worst opportunities, the worst experiences, the worst
互联网上流传着各种表情包。生活和人们说，杀不死我的，只会让我更强大。这几乎成了对待创伤的默认态度，对吧？就像当坏事发生时，我们要利用这个机会变得更好。这对我来说似乎是非常典型的美国式思维，对吧？那种我们要利用最糟糕的机会、最糟糕的经历，从中创造出积极事物的想法。
experiences and make something positive out of them. Once Miranda noticed this phenomenon, he started remembering all the times he had encountered it earlier in his life, particularly in American superhero movies. So when I was growing up in Sri Lanka when I was a small boy, I remember watching the original Superman movie with Christopher Reeve and Marlon Brando. What's your background? Where do you hail from? Well, it's kind of hard to explain, actually.
一旦Miranda注意到这种现象，他就开始回忆起他生命中更早遇到这种情况的所有时刻，特别是在美国超级英雄电影中。所以当我在斯里兰卡长大，还是个小男孩时，我记得看了克里斯托弗·里夫和马龙·白兰度主演的原版《超人》电影。你的背景是什么？你来自哪里？嗯，其实很难解释。
See, I'm from, well, pretty far away. Another galaxy, as a matter of fact. And the movie begins with Superman as an infant, leaving the planet Krypton, before it's destroyed, trying to earth, growing up on earth, realizing he has superpowers and then becoming a superhero. And when I was destroyed, trying to earth, growing up on earth, realizing he has superpowers and then becoming a superhero. And when I was young, I just thought,
你看，我来自，嗯，很远的地方。事实上是另一个星系。电影开头是婴儿时期的超人，在氪星被摧毁前离开，前往地球，在地球上长大，意识到自己有超能力，然后成为超级英雄。当我年轻的时候，我只是想，
oh, this is a cool superhero story. And then once I moved to the US, I realized, well, it's interesting that so many superhero stories, the Batman movies, for example, or Spider-Man, right? So this is, to tend to follow a very similar plot. So the protagonist goes through some type of trauma, adverse event, and somehow that event is a catalyst. The story of my life is not for the faint of heart.
哦，这是一个很酷的超级英雄故事。然后当我搬到美国后，我意识到，嗯，很有趣的是，这么多超级英雄故事，比如《蝙蝠侠》电影，或者《蜘蛛侠》，对吧？所以这些往往遵循非常相似的情节。主角经历某种创伤、逆境事件，不知何故该事件成为了催化剂。我的人生故事不适合胆小的人。
If somebody said it was a happy little tale, if somebody told you I was just your average ordinary guy not a care in the world, somebody lied. And I think buried in that narrative, right? It's this idea that that narrative, right? It's this idea that, you know, bad things, right? In some cases, can lead to this growth or the development specific abilities that makes you better off than before and also better off than
如果有人说这是一个快乐的小故事，如果有人告诉你我只是一个普通人，无忧无虑，那个人在撒谎。我认为埋藏在那种叙事中的是这种想法，你知道，坏事在某些情况下，可以导致这种成长或特定能力的开发，使你比以前更好，也比大多数其他人更好。
most other people. And what I find fascinating, of course, is that this way of thinking about suffering is not new in America. In the 1950s, books and sermons by the clergyman Norman Vincent Peale became enormously influential. The world is full of problems.
当然，我发现令人着迷的是，这种关于苦难的思考方式在美国并不新鲜。在20世纪50年代，牧师诺曼·文森特·皮尔的书籍和布道产生了巨大的影响。世界充满了问题。
For what reason? Why do we have so many problems? Why do you have so many problems? There's one answer to that. It is that you will grow strong, so that you're more and more capable of handling problems. The only way to make a strong man is through resistance, struggle, pain, frustration, disappointment. This makes man. When I listen to that clip from Norman Vincent Peel, he's not just saying that suffering produces growth.
为了什么原因？为什么我们有这么多问题？为什么你有这么多问题？答案只有一个。那就是你会变得强大，这样你就越来越有能力处理问题。造就强者的唯一途径是通过阻力、斗争、痛苦、挫折和失望。这造就了人。当我听诺曼·文森特·皮尔的那段录音时，他不仅仅是在说苦难产生增长。
He's actually saying, suffering exists in your life in order to produce growth. Right, and that's a very interesting claim, right? This idea that to some extent, in order for you to become the best person, you can be in order for you to sort of best person you can be, in order for you to sort of grow and character, suffering is necessary, right? And it makes it wonder whether that has something to do with the history of the United States, especially for people who had the freedom to immigrate to the United States, right? I mean, I think when they came to the US, there was this belief that
他实际上是在说，苦难存在于你的生活中是为了产生增长。没错，这是一个非常有趣的说法，对吧？这种想法在某种程度上，为了让你成为你能成为的最好的人，为了让你在性格上成长，苦难是必要的，对吧？这让人怀疑这是否与美国的历史有关，特别是对于那些有自由移民到美国的人来说，对吧？我的意思是，我认为当他们来到美国时，有一种信念，即
the US is this land of plenty, there's all this opportunity, it's up to you to make the most of it. And to the extent to which you're not able to make the most of it, it's because of something that you're not doing. And I wonder whether that culture belief is consistent with this view, that pain and suffering are opportunities for growth for change. Now, this way of thinking about trauma and suffering are opportunities for growth, for change. Now, this way of thinking about trauma and suffering is arguably no longer purely American.
美国是这片富饶的土地，有各种机会，由你来充分利用它。如果你不能充分利用它，那是因为你没有做某些事情。我想知道这种文化信念是否与这种观点一致，即痛苦和苦难是成长和改变的机会。现在，这种关于创伤和苦难是成长和改变的机会的思考方式，可以说不再仅仅是美国式的了。
I feel like I've heard this theme now in many other contexts, perhaps because, you know, American culture increasingly permeates the whole world. But there are videos on TikTok and WhatsApp that talk about how, you know, like Generation One confronted suffering, built its character and pulled itself up by the bootstraps, Generation Two built on that hard work to create great companies or acquire political power.
我觉得我现在在许多其他语境中也听过这个主题，也许是因为，你知道，美国文化日益渗透到全世界。但在TikTok和WhatsApp上有一些视频谈论，你知道，第一代人面对苦难，建立了性格，白手起家；第二代人在那份辛勤工作的基础上创造了大公司或获得了政治权力。
And then Generation Three squanders at all because those kids grew up in luxury and were not tested by adversity. Do you think it's possible that to some extent some of this American attitude has now started to rub off on the rest of the world as well, the sense that, you know, suffering exists in some ways to allow you to become a better version of yourself. I think there's something to that. You know, a couple of weeks ago in my graduate personality seminar, I was talking with my students about this narrative that adversity and trauma can lead to positive outcomes.
然后第三代人挥霍了一切，因为那些孩子在奢侈中长大，没有受到逆境的考验。你认为在某种程度上，这种美国式态度现在已经开始影响世界其他地区了吗？那种认为苦难在某种程度上是为了让你成为更好的自己的感觉。我认为这有一定道理。你知道，几周前在我的研究生人格研讨会上，我和学生们讨论了关于逆境和创伤可以导致积极结果的叙事。
And one of my students, who is originally from China, said, well, I do think this narrative is there in other countries as well, including in my country. What's interesting and different though is that in China, the idea is that adversity and suffering can lead to positive change at the national level, right? So that the country and the community can benefit. And he said there's a clear difference from maybe how American could think about the value
我的一位来自中国的学生说，嗯，我确实认为这种叙事在其他国家也存在，包括我的国家。但有趣且不同的是，在中国，这种想法是逆境和苦难可以在国家层面导致积极的改变，对吧？所以国家和社区可以受益。他说这与美国人思考逆境和苦难价值的方式有明显的不同，
of adversity and suffering, because they were seen in terms of its value to the individual, its value to personal transformation. Very interesting. Now, you notice this theme of triumph over trauma turning up in the lives of the people you were getting to know in the United States.
因为它们被视为对个人有价值，对个人转型有价值。非常有趣。现在，你注意到这种战胜创伤的主题出现在你在美国结识的人的生活中。
Tell me about Meredith Rousseau, who she was and how you became acquainted around her So Meredith Rousseau she was a retired English instructor She was very kind to me. I How set for her multiple times she would allow me to use her house to throw dinner parties for my friends And she was just a very kind generous welcome in presence While I was in college, as an international student. So I remember when she told me about her illness, and I went to visit her almost immediately,
告诉我关于Meredith Rousseau的事，她是谁，你是如何认识她的？Meredith Rousseau是一位退休的英语讲师。她对我非常友善。我多次为她看家，她允许我用她的房子为我的朋友举办晚宴。当我还在上大学作为国际学生时，她是一个非常善良、慷慨、受欢迎的存在。所以我记得当她告诉我她的病情时，我几乎立刻就去探望她，
and she simply said, well, you know, I have cancer, the prognosis isn't good, but, you know, we're going to take it day by day. And then she went on to talk about how part of what she was experiencing after her diagnosis were people talking about how she was going to fight the cancer like a warrior that she was going to defeat it. It was really important to sort of take the right attitude about fighting cancer. She thought, well, it seems like a lot of stress to think about cancer is something to
她只是说，嗯，你知道，我得了癌症，预后不太好，但是，你知道，我们要过一天算一天。然后她继续谈论她在诊断后所经历的一部分是人们谈论她将如何像战士一样与癌症抗争，她将如何打败它。采取正确的态度去对抗癌症真的很重要。她想，嗯，把癌症视为需要被征服的东西似乎压力太大了。我有它。我会尽我所能去应对。我可能没有多少时间了，但我会专注于重要的事情。这种关于成为战士、关于克服甚至通过打败癌症而成长，似乎……我正在努力寻找合适的词，这似乎是不必要的。她不喜欢人们鼓励她对这种疾病采取这种更像战士的立场。
be wankished. I have it. I'm going to manage with the best I can. I probably don't have a lot of time left, but I'm going to focus on what's important. It seems like this idea of being a warrior about some of the overcoming and maybe even growing from defeating cancer, it's truckers almost, I'm trying to find the right word here. It's truckers almost unnecessary. And she didn't like the fact that people were sort of encouraging her to take this more,
（续上）她不喜欢人们鼓励她对这种疾病采取这种更像战士的立场。
almost warrior-like position towards the illness. Yeah, so people are telling her, you're gonna come out stronger than before or there's a reason this is happening. And for the person who's actually suffering from the cancer, it now feels like they not only have to deal with the cancer, but they have to deal now with the expectations that they've been bequeathed a gift to actually become some kind of superior person, some kind of superhero. Exactly. And I think it's especially strange to be given that
是的，所以人们告诉她，你会比以前更强大，或者这件事发生是有原因的。对于真正患有癌症的人来说，现在感觉他们不仅要应对癌症，还要应对他们被赋予了一种天赋，即实际上成为某种优越的人、某种超级英雄的期望。没错。而且我认为被给予那种建议真的很奇怪，对吧，即这是一个天赋，这是一个机会。当你还在思考当你得到消息时的情绪反应时，对吧，从“哦，你有这种非常严重的情况”到“哦，但这是一个你可以学习的机会”转变似乎太快了。这是一个你可以提升性格、成为最好的自己的机会。所以到这个时候，你开始成为宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家，你在读研究生，你发现战胜逆境的套路，
type of advice, right, that this is a gift, this is opportunity. When you are still sort of thinking about the emotional response that you have when you're given the news, right, that it seems very quick to move from, oh, you have this like very serious situation to, oh, but this is opportunity that you can learn from. This is an opportunity where you can sort of grow your character, become the best possible version of yourself. So by this point, you were starting to become a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania, you were in grad school, and you discovered that the triumphant over adversity trope,
或者说超级英雄套路，不仅在美国流行文化中占据主导地位，而且是心理学研究中一个蓬勃发展的领域。你能告诉我关于创伤后成长的想法吗？那意味着什么，它如何与这个更大的文化套路联系起来？创伤后成长指的是人们在经历压力生活事件后可以经历积极心理变化的想法。
or the superhero trope, was not only dominant in American popular culture, but it was a booming area in psychological research. Can you tell me about the idea of post-traumatic growth? What does that mean and how that connected with this larger cultural trope? Post-traumatic growth refers to this idea that people can experience positive psychological changes as a result of going through stressful life experiences.
创伤后成长的研究始于20世纪90年代中期。我认为很多关于创伤后成长的早期研究是基于临床医生与经历过创伤、逆境的客户进行的访谈。他们试图对这些客户在临床访谈中报告的利益类型进行分类。在过去的20年里，你知道，对创伤后成长的研究和兴趣已经爆炸式增长。我可以告诉你，在过去六个月里，我想我至少看到了三篇关于COVID后创伤后成长的论文。我相信还有不少正在筹备中。即使一些临床医生告诉病人创伤事件可能导致成长，其他研究人员说，等等。人们报告成长是因为他们真的成长了吗？还是因为超级英雄套路在文化中太占主导地位了？Irranda引用了研究员Patricia Frazier的一篇论文。所以当我开始对研究创伤后成长感兴趣时，我还是个研究生。我记得读过这篇论文。这是一篇非常优雅、简单的论文。
Research in post-traumatic growth starts you know, started taking off in the mid 1990s. And a lot of the early research and post-traumatic growth, I think, was based on interviews that clinicians were doing with clients who had gone through trauma, gone through adversity. And they were trying to categorize the types of benefits these clients would report in their clinical interviews. And in the last 20 years, you know, work and research and interest in post-traumatic growth has exploded. I can tell you that in the last six months, I think I've seen at least three papers looking
这是一项短期纵向研究。所以这是一项在几个月内跟踪大量本科生的研究。它询问他们是否经历了重大的压力事件，然后被问到，好的，由于压力事件，你因为创伤改变了多少？事实证明，这个问题“你认为你因为创伤改变了多少”，是大多数创伤后成长衡量标准询问变化的方式。
at post-traumatic growth in the wake of COVID. And I'm sure there are quite a few more that are in the pipeline. Even as some clinicians were telling patients that traumatic events could lead to growth, other researchers said, hang on. Are people reporting growth because they've grown? Or are they saying so because the superhero trope is so dominant in the culture. Irranda cites a paper by the research of Patricia Frazier. So I was a graduate student when I started becoming interested in looking at post-traumatic growth. And I remember reading this paper when it came out. And it was a very elegant, simple paper.
这篇论文让我意识到，尽管大多数关于创伤后成长的理论都在谈论人格转型方面的创伤后成长，但创伤后成长的衡量标准实际上是在看不同的东西，即对变化的感知。他们发现，虽然经历过真正改变的人有更好的心理健康质量，但那些报告感知到高度改变的人，作为经历创伤或逆境事件的结果，实际上报告了高水平的心理困扰。所以从一个现在正在审视这种更大的美国文化套路的人的角度来看，我现在称之为超级英雄套路，即坏事会在你内心产生非凡的品质，说这项研究在某种程度上指出，如果你非常强烈地认同这种信念，即超级英雄套路信念，但生活中并没有实际发生改变，这公平吗？不仅不好，实际上可能是有害的。我认为是对的。发生的事情是，人们持有关于利益或成长的这些信念，作为应对他们所经历的创伤事件的一种方式。
It was a short-term, longitudinal study. So it was a study that tracked a large number of undergraduate students over a few months. And it asked them whether they experienced a major stressful event, and then they were asked, okay, since as a result of the stressful event, how much have you changed because of the trauma? And so it turns out that this question, how much do you think you've changed because of the trauma, is the way most measures of post-traumatic growth
在某种程度上，持有这些信念可能起到了让他们以更可控的方式思考事件的作用，也许让他们对事件建立了更大的控制感。我认为Frazier论文的一个教训是，这种感知成长的应对策略似乎并不是一种特别有效的策略，至少对于样本来说是这样。现在还有另一项研究，这项研究是针对部署到伊拉克的士兵进行的。你能告诉我那篇论文发现了什么吗？是的，这是一篇观察部署到伊拉克的荷兰士兵的论文。这篇论文的好处是它跟踪了人们，我想，跨越了15个月。
asks about change. And this paper made me realize that even though most theories about post-traumatic growth were talking about post-traumatic growth in terms of personality transformation, the measures of post-traumatic growth were actually looking at something different, which was the perception of change. And what they found was that while people who had experienced real change had better quality mental health, the people who reported perceiving high levels of change, as a result of experiencing the trauma or the adverse event, actually reported high levels of mental distress. So from the point of view of someone who was now just looking at this larger
这篇论文明确探讨了感知成长是否作为一种适应性应对策略的问题。他们发现感知成长实际上预示了PTSD症状方面损害的增加。换句话说，那些认为自己因逆境而成长了的士兵，实际上比其他士兵更有可能经历PTSD症状。这种信念本应有所帮助，但它导致了更糟糕的结果。然而，经历创伤的人会从创伤中受益的想法被证明是不可抗拒的。这种套路越来越多地被积极推荐给病人作为康复的途径。大约10或15年前，人们对在癌症患者中推广这些关于创伤后成长的信念非常感兴趣，因为有一种信念认为也许成长可以帮助他们提高生活质量。这导致了一场相当激烈的辩论，你有一方研究人员主张创伤后成长，谈论成长的潜在好处，谈论很大比例的人报告高水平的成长，然后你有了反对者说，我们还没有正确区分感知成长和创伤后成长。现有的证据表明，被理解为感知变化的成长
American cultural trope, what I'm going to now call the superhero trope, that bad things produce extraordinary qualities to come out inside you, is it fair to say that this study in some ways was pointing to the fact that if you subscribe very strongly to this belief, the superhero trope belief, but didn't actually have the changes in your life. Not only was this not good, but it could actually be bad. I think that's right. What was happening was that people were having these beliefs about benefits or growth that experience as a way to cope with the traumatic event that had gone through.
对癌症患者的生活质量或寿命没有重大影响。这说明了在真正验证这种超级英雄套路的文化背景下进行此类研究的挑战之一，对吧，或者这种认为逆境可以导致这些积极结果的想法。我认为人们很容易接受符合他们既有信念的研究。我认为当我发表我的成长研究时，人们愿意跳过步骤，在获得正确证据之前就对证据做出强有力的主张。
So in some ways, having these beliefs was potentially serving the role of making them think about their event in a more manageable way, maybe make them establish a greater sense of control over the event. And I think one lesson from the Frasier paper is that this coping strategy of perceiving growth didn't seem like a particularly effective one, at least for the sample. Now there was another study this one conducted with soldiers deployed to Iraq. Can you tell me what that paper found around it? Yes, this is a paper that looked at soldiers from the Netherlands that were deployed to Iraq. What was nice about this paper is that it tracked people, I think, across 15 months.
Around开始怀疑，创伤后成长的叙事是给人们希望和灵感，还是要求遭受创伤的人不仅要生存下来，还要展示他们已经变得更强大的证据？当我们回来时，Iran并不相信他在美国所看到的，这与他在斯里兰卡处理冲突的个人经历有关。你正在收听Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。美国文化坚持认为困难时期可以使我们成为更好、更成功的人。
This paper explicitly looked to the question of whether perceiving growth served as an adaptive coping strategy. And what they found was that perceived growth actually predicted increased impairment in terms of PTSD symptoms. In other words, the soldiers who perceived that they had grown as a result of adversity were actually more likely than other soldiers to experience symptoms of PTSD. The belief was supposed to be helping, but it led to worse outcomes. Yet the idea that people who experienced trauma would benefit from their trauma proved irresistible. Increasingly, this trope has been actively recommended to patients as a path to recovery. Around 10 or 15 years ago, there was a lot of interest in trying to promote these beliefs
杀不死我们的会让我们更强大。在移居美国学习心理学后，Iranda Jayawikrama开始询问这种流行的套路是否弊大于利。他有一个参考点，他自己在斯里兰卡长大的经历。在20世纪80年代和90年代的大部分时间里，斯里兰卡的少数民族泰米尔人和僧伽罗多数派陷入了一场残酷的内战。数万人被杀。冲突在各方都表现出可怕的残忍行为。Eranda，你在斯里兰卡内战爆发时还是个孩子。作为一个孩子，你被允许看到多少？
about post-traumatic growth among cancer patients, because there was this belief that maybe growth could help them improve the quality of life. And this led to this pretty acrimonious debate, where you had researchers advocating for post-traumatic growth, talking about the potential benefits of growth, the fact that large proportions of people report high levels of growth, and then you had detectors saying, we haven't properly distinguished between perceived growth and post-traumatic growth. And the existing evidence suggests that growth understood as perceived change
我作为一个九岁和十岁孩子在科伦坡（我们居住的地方）的日常经历是看到那些被绑架、折磨、杀害并被遗弃在街边的尸体。回顾过去，我感到震惊的是，我竟然在多大程度上认为那是正常的。我没有比较。我只是想，哦，我们不能去上学。所有这些事情都在我们周围发生，但我只是没有想太多。我认为这为高度正常化或极端暴力奠定了基础。我认为对于许多在80年代和90年代在斯里兰卡长大的人来说，这确实是常态。尽管我在一个相对富裕的中产阶级家庭长大，所以我们幸免于在起义和内战中犯下的许多可怕暴行。但这种“炸弹可能会在你乘坐的公共汽车上爆炸”的态度。如果你看到可疑的人，你必须小心。这些类型的行为和这些类型的信念变得正常化了。我记得，我们搬到康提时，我想我14岁。1998年，我想，
doesn't have a meaningful impact on the quality of life or the longevity of cancer patients. And this speaks to one of the challenges of doing this type of research in the context of a culture that really validates this superhero trope, right, or this idea that you know adversity can lead to these positive outcomes. you can lead to these positive outcomes. I think it's easy for people to accept research that speaks to their own pre-existing beliefs. And I think what happened when I posted my growth research was that people were willing to jump ahead and make strong claims about the evidence before the right kind of evidence could be procured.
当泰米尔猛虎组织炸毁佛牙寺（康提的一座主要佛教圣地）时，我们离爆炸地点几英里远。我记得我们的房子在炸弹爆炸时摇晃，炸弹爆炸的那一刻，哦，发生了什么事，我觉得很有趣的是，那天下午我感到很自在地前往市中心去看我的朋友，看看发生了什么，对吧？就像我记得去拜访住在寺庙附近的朋友，他家所有的窗户都被震碎了，但这感觉奇怪地平凡，因为我们已经习惯了当时在斯里兰卡发生的暴力类型。
Around the start to wonder, does the post-traumatic growth narrative give people hope and inspiration, or does it demand that people suffering trauma not only survive it, but show evidence they have come out stronger on the other side? When we come back, Iran did not trust what he was seeing in the United States, with his own experience of dealing with conflict in Sri Lanka. You are listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. American culture insists that hard times can make us into better, more successful people.
我的意思是，令人震惊的是你的父母竟然让你走出家门。我的意思是，你知道，两英里外发生了炸弹爆炸，几个小时后，你却溜达到朋友家。我的意思是，这有点令人震惊。我想回顾过去，可能是我们做出了一个决定，好吧，炸弹已经发生了。再次发生的可能性不大。所以我们觉得出去很自在。我还要说，确实，康提和科伦坡的人所经历的与国家北部和东部的人所经历的之间存在一定程度的差异，对吧？那些真正陷入内战的人，对吧？
What doesn't kill us makes us stronger. After moving to the United States to study psychology, Iranda Jayawikrama began to ask if this popular trope was doing more harm than good. He had a reference point, his own experience growing up in Sri Lanka. Through much of the 1980s and 90s, the minority Tamil population of Sri Lanka and the Sinalese majority were locked in a brutal civil war. Tens of thousands of people were killed. The conflict featured terrible acts of cruelty on all sides. Eranda, you were a kid in Sri Lanka when the civil war unfolded. How much were you allowed to see as a child?
所以，我认为在某种程度上，隐性或显性地，我们相信与其他人相比，这并不算太糟，对吧？如果我们没有生活在战区。我们之前谈到你如何在9·11袭击前不久移居美国。当袭击发生时，你注意到了自己对袭击的反应。你注意到了什么，Around？我记得非常生动。那天早上我在上课，当时他们宣布
My everyday experience as a nine and ten year old going around Colombo, which is where we lived, was seeing the bodies of people who had been abducted, tortured, killed, and left on the side of the street. And looking back on that, I wanted them struck by, it's just the extent to which I thought that was normal. I had no comparison. I just thought, oh, we don't get to go to school. All this stuff is happening around us, but I just didn't think too much about it. And I think that's set the stage for a
第一架飞机撞向了世界贸易中心。我认为因为在那一点上，人们仍然认为那是一次事故。我们继续上课。然后是在我当天的第一节课后，很明显这是一次协同攻击。人们处于震惊中，当天的其余课程被取消，他们架起了电视机，
pretty high degree of normalization or extreme violence. And I think for many people who grew up in Sri Lanka in the 80s and 90s, that was very much the norm. And even though I grew up in a relatively affluent middle class household, so we were spared many of the terrible atrocities that were committed both in the insurrection and in the civil war. But this attitude of a bomb might go up in you under bus. You have to be careful if you see someone suspicious. These types of behaviors and these types of beliefs just became normalised. I remember, so we moved to candy when we were, I think, 14 years old. And in 1998, I think,
他们分发食物。我的第一个想法是，嗯，这很糟糕，但它也奇怪地感觉像家。我的想法是，哦，这很糟糕，但我不认为它让我意识到这对周围其他人来说会有多糟糕。直到那天晚上晚些时候，我参加了一个跨宗教追悼会。
when the tamatikers blew up the temple of the tooth, this major Buddhist shrine in candy, so we were a couple of miles away from the blast. I remember you know our house shook when the bomb went off and the moment the bomb went off the oh something's happened and I think it was interesting that I felt comfortable traveling out to the city center that afternoon to see my friends and to see what was happening right like I remember visiting my friend who lived close to the temple and all the windows in his house had been blown through but it felt weirdly mundane because of'd degree to which we had become sort of accustomed to the type of violence that we saw going on in Sri Lanka at that time.
教授们在那里，他们在哭。他们在啜泣，因为有在那年春天毕业的学生去华尔街工作，去世界贸易中心工作。他们不知道他们在哪里。他们试图联系他们，对吧？他们悲痛欲绝。我记得那一刻我想，这里出了什么问题。
I mean, it's astonishing that your parents simply let you out of the house. I mean, you know, there was a bomb blast that went off two miles away and a few hours later, you're traipsing out to a friend's house. I mean, that's kind of astonishing. I think looking back, it might be that, you know, we made a decision that, well, the bombs already happened. Chances are something is not going to happen again. So we felt comfortable going out. And I will also say, right, and it was true that there was a degree of difference between what people in candy and crumble were experiencing and what people in the North and East of the country are experiencing, right? People who are actually caught up in the Civil War, right?
就像我似乎，我觉得我对这次袭击的反应似乎不对。我的意思是，你几乎是以一种超然的感觉在回应你周围发生的这件可怕的事情。没错。这也说明了一个事实，即当时，你知道，作为一个在斯里兰卡长大的人，对我来说看起来正常的事情，是我意识到对许多其他人来说是不正常的，至少对于生活在
So, there's, I think there's a sense in which maybe implicitly explicitly, we believe that compared to other people, this wasn't too bad, right? That if we weren't living in a war zone. We talked earlier about how you move to the United States shortly before the 9-11 attacks. When the attacks happen, you noticed something about your own reaction to the attacks. What did you notice around that? I remember this very vividly. I was in class that morning when they announced
世界这一部分的人来说。在他成为心理学家后，Iranda开始问自己，他对斯里兰卡内战创伤的反应是否揭示了成长。当他诚实地审视自己时，他没有看到成长。他看到了麻木、脱敏，甚至是冷漠。现在你可以争辩，如果你喜欢诺曼·文森特·皮尔，那种坚硬就是成长。但面对苦难时的冷漠真的是创伤使他成为更好的人的标志吗？
the first plane had a head-to-head world trade center. And I think because of that point, people thought it was still an accident. We continued with class. And then it was after my first class of the day that it became clear that this was actually a con-edit attack. People in shock and the cancer classes to the rest of the day, they set up TV sets,
当Iran回到斯里兰卡对创伤后成长进行研究时，他采访了其他被内战创伤的人。他看到了许多像他自己一样或更糟的人。和他们谈论你上周发生了什么或者什么是一件影响你生活的可怕事情是没有意义的，对吧？因为这些人经历了各种类型的多重创伤。在那些访谈中让我印象深刻的一点是，与美国不同，
and they gave out food. And my first thought was, well, this is bad, but it also weirdly feels like home. And my thought was, oh, this is bad, but I don't think it struck me just how bad it would have felt to other people around me. And it was only later that evening, there was an interfaith memorial service that I went for.
大多数斯里兰卡人不想详细谈论他们的经历，关于他们的创伤。没有关于这对我是什么样的人意味着什么，或者我可以从中成长，或者改变，或者我可以从中吸取什么教训的调查，我与人们进行的所有对话都非常客观。如果我逼问他们经历过的事情，他们只会一个接一个地列出来，就这样了。你知道，创伤对日常功能的影响程度各不相同。有一些
And there were professors who were there, and they were crying. They were sobbing because there were seniors who had graduated that spring who had gone to work on Wall Street, who had gone to work at the World Trade Center. And they didn't know where they were. They tried to contact them, right? They were beside themselves with grief. And I remember thinking at that moment, something's wrong here.
人确实表现得非常坚韧和积极，尽管经历了逆境，对吧？不多，也许一两个。但有许多人你可以看出，只是在努力维持日常运作，对吧？有一个人来和我们谈话，因为那个人希望我能帮她找到她的儿子。那是一次令人心碎的讨论，对吧？很明显她在挣扎。
Like I seem to, I feel like I'm having a response to this attack that doesn't seem right. I mean, you were almost responding with a sense of detachment to this terrible thing that was happening around you. Exactly. And it also speaks to the fact that time is that, you know, what seemed real to be normal to me as someone who grew up in Sri Lanka was something that I was realizing was not normal to many other people, at least for people who lived in,
很明显她几乎无法在日常生活中运作。但她来参加会议是因为她希望和我谈论她的儿子可能会开启一个他可能被找到的新可能性。所以你对你在斯里兰卡看到的这种方法不满意，那种让人们在痛苦中孤立的逃避，但你对美国的方法也不满意。那种告诉人们悲剧会使他们成为更好的自己的波利安娜式的乐观主义。所以你开始审视是否有第三条路，你开始寻找答案，不仅在科学中，而且在哲学和神学中。你为什么要那样做，Around，你发现了什么？
you know, in this part of the world. After he became a psychologist, Iranda started to ask himself whether his own response to the trauma of the Sri Lankan civil war revealed in our growth. When he looked at himself honestly, he didn't see growth. He saw heartening, desensitization, even indifference. Now you could argue if you like Norman Vincent Peel, that hardness is growth. But was apathy in the face of suffering really a sign that trauma had made him a better person?
我的第一个想法是，好的，在逆境可以导致改变的程度上，你期望在哪些领域看到改变？在查看哲学文献、查看不同的宗教传统、查看神学时，我有一个想法是，嗯，可能是为了强调这些不同的传统谈论苦难、如何处理它、如何超越它。可能存在来自这些不同传统的宝贵见解。在过去的几年里，有许多人争辩说宗教的一个基本作用
When Iran then returned to Sri Lanka to do research on post-traumatic growth, he interviewed other people who had been traumatized by the civil war. He saw lots of people who were like himself or worse. It makes no sense to talk to them about what happened to you last week or what was a terrible thing that has impacted your life, right? Because these are people of undergone multiple traumas of all types. And one thing that struck home for me in those interviews is that unlike in the United States,
不是告诉你一个关于创造的故事，或者告诉你一个关于为什么你应该成为一个好人的故事。宗教的基本作用是帮助我们理解为什么世界上有苦难和创伤。为什么我们爱的人会生病并在某个时候离开我们？为什么我们遭受不可避免的痛苦、不应得的苦难？
most shirankers don't want to talk at length about their experiences, about their trauma. There's no sort of investigation into what this means for who am I as a person, or what I can grow for me, or change for me, or what lessen I can take for me, all the conversations I had with people are very matter of fact. If I pushed them on the experiences I had, they would just sort of list them one after another and that would be it. You know, the extent to which it was clear that day-to-day function had been impacted by trauma varied. There were some
这些是我们无法立即理性回答的基本存在主义问题。所以，我的想法是，查看不同的宗教、查看神学、查看不同的哲学传统，我试图解释苦难和逆境的作用和价值，这些传统可能会让我们更好地理解我们可以在哪里看到改变。在佛教传统中，有这样一种想法，即
people who did come across as very resilient and very positive despite that adversities had gone through, right? Not too many, maybe one or two. But there were many people who you could tell, but just struggling to function day to day, right? There was one person who came to speak to us because that person was hoping that I could help her find her son. And that was like a heartbreaking discussion to have, right? You know, it was clear she was struggling.
理解生活本质上是关于苦难是很重要的。一旦他们接受了关于生活的那个核心真理，它就为你获得特定的美德打开了可能性，即慈悲，这将使你过上美好的生活。同样，在基督教传统中，苦难可以提供给我们的一个教训是，我们是脆弱的生物，
It was clear that she could barely function in daily life. But she came to the meeting because she was hoping that talking to me about her son would maybe open up a new possibility that he could be found. So you weren't satisfied with the approach that you were seeing in Sri Lanka, kind of avoidance that left people isolated in their pain, but you also weren't satisfied with the American approach. This polyanish optimism that told people that tragedy would make them better versions of themselves. So you started to examine if there was a third way and you began to look for answers, not just in science, but in philosophy and theology. Why did you do that around there and what did you find?
我们需要其他人，我们本质上是相互依赖的，而这种洞察力是苦难可以教给你的可用教训。所以你开始了自己的研究，关于逆境在促进这种性格发展中的作用，并且你开始警觉到心理学内部一个新兴的研究领域。
My first thought was, okay, to the extent to which adversity can lead to change, in what domains would you expect to see change? And in looking at the, you know, the literature in philosophy, looking at different religious traditions, looking at theology, one idea ahead was that, well, it might be that to accentuate these different traditions, talk about suffering, how to deal with it, how to move past it. There might be valuable insights that could come from these different traditions. And in the last few years, there been many people have argued that a fundamental role
我最初的想法是，好吧，在逆境能够带来改变的程度上，你期望在哪些领域看到改变？在查阅哲学文献、研究不同的宗教传统以及神学时，我产生的一个想法是，这些不同的传统可能会强调关于苦难的讨论，即如何应对苦难，如何克服苦难。这些不同的传统可能会提供有价值的见解。在过去几年里，许多人认为宗教的一个基本作用
of religion isn't to tell you a story about creation, or to tell you a story about why you should be a good person. The fundamental role of religion is to help us understand why they're suffering and trauma in the world. Why do the people that we love get sick and leave us at some point? Why do we suffer unavoidable pain, undeserved suffering?
并不是为了给你讲述一个关于创世的故事，也不是为了告诉你为什么要成为一个好人。宗教的基本作用是帮助我们理解为什么世界上会有苦难和创伤。为什么我们所爱的人会生病，并在某个时刻离开我们？为什么我们要承受不可避免的痛苦和不应得的苦难？
These are fundamental existential questions that we can't, you know, immediately answer rationally. So, my thought was that looking at different religions, looking at theology, looking at different philosophical traditions that I try to explain the role and value of suffering and adversity, these traditions might give us a better understanding of where we could see change. In the Buddhist tradition, there's this idea that
这些都是我们无法立即理性回答的基本存在主义问题。因此，我的想法是，通过研究不同的宗教、神学以及试图解释苦难和逆境的作用与价值的哲学传统，这些传统可能会让我们更好地理解我们可以在哪里看到改变。在佛教传统中，有这样一种观点：
it's important to understand that life is fundamentally about suffering. And once they accept that core truth about life, it opens up the possibility for you to attain specific virtues, that compassion, that would enable you to lead a good life. Similarly, in the Christian tradition, one lesson that suffering can provide us is that we are vulnerable creatures,
理解生活本质上是苦难的这一点很重要。一旦你接受了关于生活的这一核心真理，它就为你获得特定的美德（如慈悲）打开了大门，使你能够过上美好的生活。同样，在基督教传统中，苦难能教给我们的一个教训是，我们是脆弱的生物，
that we need other people that we're fundamentally independent, and that insight is available listen that suffering can teach you. So you began your own research on the role of adversity in promoting this kind of character development, and you became alert to an emerging body of research within psychology
我们需要他人，我们本质上是相互依赖的，而这种洞察力正是苦难所能教给你的。于是，你开始了关于逆境在促进这种性格发展中作用的研究，并开始关注心理学领域内新兴的研究成果。
that was demonstrating the potential for suffering to lead to things like compassion or wisdom or creativity. For example, you found the work of the psychologist David Distanneudani-Lem who had examined empirically how adversity affected people's capacity for compassion. Tell me what they found around them. They assessed adversity through a checklist where people were asked across your whole life, tell us what major stressful life events we experienced. And what they found was that if you look to the relationship between the number of adverse life events
这展示了苦难可能带来同情心、智慧或创造力等特质的潜力。例如，你发现了心理学家大卫·迪斯塔诺（David DeSteno）的研究，他通过实证考察了逆境如何影响人们的同情心。告诉我他们发现了什么。他们通过一份清单来评估逆境，询问人们一生中经历过哪些重大的压力事件。他们发现，如果你观察逆境事件数量与同情心表达之间的关系，
people reported in their lifetime and the expression of compassion, they found that people who were experienced high levels of community life and adversity were more compassionate. They were more willing to engage in pro-social behavior. They also found that to accentuate your experience high levels of community of lifetime adversity, you were less prone
人们报告说，在他们的一生中，经历过高水平社区生活和逆境的人更有同情心。他们更愿意参与亲社会行为。他们还发现，要强调你经历过高水平的社区生活和终身逆境，你就不太容易
to be overwhelmed by the number of people who were suffering, right? So this is called the numeracy bias. So the idea is that when you see one person suffering, you feel like, oh, I can do something with that person. But when you hear that, like, a whole country has a refugee crisis, you tend not to get involved because you feel like, well, this is overwhelming. I don't think I can do anything about this. So I'm not going to engage. It turns out that people who have experienced a high level of lifetime adversity are immune to this bias. So, one implication from these studies is that they, something about experiencing different
被受苦难的人数所淹没，对吧？这被称为“数字偏见”（numeracy bias）。所以这个想法是，当你看到一个人受苦时，你会觉得，哦，我可以为那个人做点什么。但当你听说整个国家发生难民危机时，你往往不会参与，因为你觉得，嗯，这太让人不知所措了。我不认为我能为此做些什么。所以我不会参与。事实证明，经历过高水平终身逆境的人对这种偏见有免疫力。因此，这些研究的一个启示是，经历不同
types of adverse events that seems to increase your empathy towards other people, that seems to make you most sensitive to the needs of others. In other words, suffering and trauma don't always produce growth. When they do, that growth is unlikely to follow the arc of your standard superhero movie. Instead of getting tougher, growth may take the form of increased compassion and empathy. There are caveats however. Trauma can also decrease empathy and compassion. Remember how Iran responded to the 9-11 attacks. It turns out trauma alone usually does not produce wisdom and compassion. A lot comes down to how you process trauma, how
类型的逆境事件似乎能增加你对他人的同理心，似乎能让你对他人的需求最敏感。换句话说，苦难和创伤并不总是产生增长。当它们产生增长时，这种增长不太可能遵循标准超级英雄电影的弧线。增长可能表现为同情心和同理心的增强，而不是变得更强硬。然而，也有一些警告。创伤也可能降低同理心和同情心。记住伊朗对9-11袭击的反应。事实证明，创伤本身通常不会产生智慧和同情心。很多事情归结为你如何处理创伤，如何
you reflect on your own suffering. One study along these lines was conducted by the psychologists, Judith Gluck and Nick Westreth. Yes, so you've just been doing research on wisdom for many years now and Nick Westreth, later project with her, looking at what predicts whether someone experiences changes and well-being in the wake of adverse life events. And they found that how you thought about the event was a critical factor in determining whether you subsequently experienced changes in wisdom and changes in well-being. Specifically, Nick and you that looked at this construct called exploratory processing, are the extent to which you sort of reflect on the event, right? You try and think, okay, what
反思你自己的苦难。心理学家朱迪思·格鲁克（Judith Glück）和尼克·韦斯特拉特（Nick Weststrate）进行了这方面的一项研究。是的，你多年来一直在研究智慧，而尼克·韦斯特拉特后来与你合作，研究是什么预测了某人在经历逆境事件后是否会经历幸福感的变化。他们发现，你如何看待这一事件是决定你随后是否经历智慧和幸福感变化的关键因素。具体来说，尼克和你研究了这种被称为“探索性加工”（exploratory processing）的结构，即你在多大程度上反思这一事件，对吧？你试着思考，好吧，这个
this is event mean to me? How do I make sense of this? How can I use this event as an opportunity for me to do something different with my life? And in a study that they ran a few years ago, they found that to the extent to which people engage in that type of self-reflection, those people are much more likely to increase in wisdom and increase in well-being after going through a change in life event. Setbacks in adversity do not magically produce growth and build character. Trauma is just as likely to cause us to turn away from others and become embittered. When we come back, how to cultivate character strengths, following setbacks and adversity.
事件对我意味着什么？我该如何理解这一点？我怎样才能利用这个事件作为机会，让我的生活有所不同？在他们几年前进行的一项研究中，他们发现，人们进行这种自我反思的程度越高，他们在经历生活事件的变化后，智慧和幸福感增加的可能性就越大。挫折和逆境并不会神奇地产生增长并塑造性格。创伤同样可能导致我们背离他人并变得愤世嫉俗。回来后，我们将探讨如何在挫折和逆境之后培养性格优势。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Aranda Jaya Vikramma is a psychologist at Wake Forest University. He studies how we respond to hardships. He explores how suffering can provide a platform for cultivating character strengths like compassion, wisdom and resourcefulness. Irranda, you've long been inspired by Victor Frankel,
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。阿兰达·贾亚维克拉马（Aranda Jaya Vikramma）是维克森林大学的心理学家。他研究我们如何应对困难。他探索苦难如何为培养同情心、智慧和足智多谋等性格优势提供平台。阿兰达，你长期以来一直受到维克多·弗兰克尔（Victor Frankl）的启发，
the Holocaust survivor who wrote man's search for meaning. Can you tell our listeners what the book is about and how it's spoken to you? So yeah, I remember reading Victor Frankel as a sophomore in college. And I remember even back then, being struck by the message of the book. The book is about the experience that Victor Franco had in a concentration camp during the Second World
那位写了《活出意义来》（Man's Search for Meaning）的大屠杀幸存者。你能告诉我们的听众这本书是关于什么的，以及它对你有什么影响吗？是的，我记得我在大学二年级时读过维克多·弗兰克尔的书。我记得即使在当时，我也被书中的信息所震撼。这本书是关于维克多·弗兰克尔在第二次世界大战期间在集中营的经历。
War. And specifically, it was about his experience how he was able to maintain a sense of control over his life, despite the complete lack of control he had from an objective standpoint. And one of the core lessons of that book is, even when you have no control over your environment, you can still exert some degree of control over your reaction to the environment, especially in context where you feel like there's nothing you can do to make the situation better.
具体来说，是关于他的经历，尽管从客观角度来看他完全缺乏控制力，但他如何能够保持对自己生活的控制感。这本书的核心教训之一是，即使当你对环境没有任何控制力时，你仍然可以对你对环境的反应施加一定程度的控制，特别是在你觉得无法做任何事情来改善情况的情况下。
Believe it or not, at least I can control my own reaction to the situation, I think gives you some degree of agency, right? That allows you to both maintain an adequate level of well-being in the moment, and also, you know, maintain some degree of hope to think that well, things are terrible now, but at least they're supposed to be able to be better in the future. So psychological research has begun to build on testimonies like this, this idea that we can choose our own responses
信不信由你，至少我可以控制自己对这种情况的反应，我认为这给了你一定程度的能动性，对吧？这让你既能在当下保持足够的幸福感，也能保持一定程度的希望，认为虽然现在情况很糟糕，但至少未来可能会好转。因此，心理学研究已经开始建立在这样的证词之上，即我们可以选择自己的反应
to adversity. And this research makes a distinction between what's called primary control and secondary control. What are those two modes of control, Miranda? Primary control is what I think most people, at least most Americans, would think of as a control or agency. It's when you use your own actions to modify or change the environment.
来应对逆境。这项研究区分了所谓的“初级控制”（primary control）和“次级控制”（secondary control）。这两种控制模式是什么，阿兰达？初级控制是我认为大多数人，至少大多数美国人会认为是控制或能动性的东西。这是当你利用自己的行动来修改或改变环境时。
Security control is when you can't change the environment. Or maybe for example, the health diagnosis, you just can't change objectively. In those cases, the focus of control is not on the environment, but on your own thoughts. So while primary control involves changing the environment, secondary control involves changing your own reaction to the environment. There's been a lot of work that looks at the difference between these two approaches in a study that you conducted with Eric Helzer. You assessed how much people exercised this control over the external world versus control
次级控制是当你无法改变环境时。或者也许例如，健康诊断，你只是无法客观地改变它。在这些情况下，控制的焦点不在于环境，而在于你自己的思想。因此，虽然初级控制涉及改变环境，但次级控制涉及改变你对自己对环境的反应。有很多工作研究了这两种方法之间的区别，在你与埃里克·赫尔泽（Eric Helzer）进行的一项研究中。你评估了人们在多大程度上对外部世界行使这种控制，与对
over the internal world and then you measured how satisfied they were with their lives. Can you describe the study for me and what you found around there? You know, we had this idea that primary security control worked together to promote well being. In the literature, there's an assumption that primary control is what's most important and that you fall back at security control when you don't have an option with the hope that in the future, you can then revert back to primary control. Our perspective was that, well, no, maybe we use these different control strategies as
内部世界行使控制，然后你测量了他们对生活的满意度。你能为我描述一下这项研究以及你在那里发现了什么吗？你知道，我们有这样一个想法，即初级和次级控制共同促进幸福感。在文献中，有一种假设认为初级控制是最重要的，当你没有选择时，你会退回到次级控制，并希望在未来，你可以恢复到初级控制。我们的观点是，好吧，不，也许我们使用这些不同的控制策略作为
tools to deal with different types of challenges in our world. So we ran a study to look at the unique impact each of these control strategies had on well-being. And we found that these two strategies independently predicted well-being, primary control or control over environment, tended to be associated with high levels of possible emotions, whereas secondary control had this relationship with life satisfaction.
工具来应对我们世界中不同类型的挑战。因此，我们进行了一项研究，以观察这些控制策略中每一种对幸福感的独特影响。我们发现，这两种策略独立地预测了幸福感，初级控制或对环境的控制往往与高水平的积极情绪相关，而次级控制则与生活满意度有关。
So they're both very tools that we can use to promote our wellbeing in daily life. So in other words, when it is absolutely the case that trying to limit the traumas that affect us, changing the external world, obviously that does help, that is, that does produce positive outcomes, it is also the case that changing our response
所以它们都是我们可以用来促进日常生活中幸福感的工具。换句话说，当绝对有必要限制影响我们的创伤、改变外部世界时，这显然是有帮助的，确实会产生积极的结果，但同样地，改变我们对
to those traumatic events that independently can also promote our well-being. Exactly, and it can do so in a number of different ways, right? It can do so by helping us sort of accept the change that's happening in our lives. Doing so also gives us a sense of agency control, right? We don't feel overwhelmed by the event. We don't feel like this event has somehow sort of taken over a sense of self
这些创伤事件的反应，这独立地也能促进我们的幸福感。没错，而且它可以通过多种不同的方式做到这一点，对吧？它可以通过帮助我们接受生活中正在发生的变化来做到这一点。这样做也给了我们一种能动性和控制感，对吧？我们不会觉得被事件淹没。我们不会觉得这个事件以某种方式接管了我们的自我感，
has made us lose a sense of control over our lives And it makes the event more manageable So there was a time in your own life around where you had to lean on your own capacity to exert secondary control In other words to exert control over your own your own reactions not the not the external world Can you tell me about what happened in Sri Lanka in 2004? You were enrolled in college at the time and the events that were unfolding were taking place thousands of miles away.
让我们失去了对生活的控制感，这使得事件更容易管理。所以，阿兰达，在你自己的生活中，有一段时间你不得不依靠自己施加次级控制的能力。换句话说，对你自己的反应施加控制，而不是对外部世界。你能告诉我2004年在斯里兰卡发生了什么吗？你当时正在上大学，而正在发生的事件发生在几千英里之外。
Walk me through what happened. So I remember I think it was, Chris was in 2004 and at some point in the night I got a message from my father saying that there had been a tsunami that hit Sri Lanka. And I remember that morning waking up and watching the news and seeing like these terrible scenes of people being swept through city centers by, you know, these waves of water. And he felt overwhelming because
带我了解一下发生了什么。所以我记得，我想是2004年，有一天晚上我收到父亲的消息，说斯里兰卡发生了海啸。我记得那天早上醒来，看新闻，看到人们被海浪冲过市中心的那些可怕场景。这让人感到不知所措，因为
all the next few days, all these stories came out of the number of people who had been killed, the level of devastation on the eastern coast, on the southern coast, there was a train that was traveling down from Colombo to South of the country, and the wave that came for tsunami engulfed the train and pulled it into the sea and then washed it back up a show, right? And many of these people on that train were lost. So there were all these terrible stories that were coming out, and I, you know, felt completely helpless, right?
在接下来的几天里，所有关于遇难人数、东海岸和南海岸破坏程度的故事都出来了，有一列火车从科伦坡开往该国南部，海啸带来的海浪吞没了火车，把它拉进海里，然后又把它冲回岸上，对吧？火车上的许多人都失踪了。所以所有这些可怕的故事都传了出来，我感到完全无助，对吧？
I was worried about my parents, or thankfully they were not impacted that badly by the tsunami. I was worried about the impact this would have on the friends I had there, the people in the country. And it wasn't an internet I could do, because I was like a college student and it's finally a, in Lancaster, Pennsylvania. So I remember thinking, well, I can't do anything to fix it. I just had to figure out how to manage with the fact that this terrible thing has happened and accept the fact that I can't
我担心我的父母，谢天谢地，他们没有受到海啸的太大影响。我担心这对我在那里的朋友、国家的人民会产生什么影响。我无能为力，因为我只是宾夕法尼亚州兰开斯特的一名大学生。所以我记得当时想，好吧，我无法做任何事情来解决它。我只是必须弄清楚如何应对这件可怕的事情已经发生的事实，并接受我无法
do anything about it right now. I will say that relying on secondary control at that point in time helps facilitate a more primary control response in the spring. Because in the spring of that year, I worked with some friends of mine to raise funds for people impacted by the tsunami. And it ended up becoming one of the most meaningful experiences of my college career. And this is why I think these different control strategies can be so helpful because depending on where you are at the moment, depending on what you can
现在对此做任何事情的事实。我要说的是，在那一刻依靠次级控制有助于促进春季的初级控制反应。因为在那一年的春天，我和一些朋友一起为受海啸影响的人筹集资金。这最终成为我大学生涯中最有意义的经历之一。这就是为什么我认为这些不同的控制策略非常有帮助，因为根据你当下的处境，根据你当下能
and can't do in the moment, selectively utilizing these different strategies can be very helpful. And I do think in the case of the tsunami, I was able to get to a place in the spring where I was then able to exert primary control and do something that I hopefully was helpful to people in Sri Lanka. So another practice that's supported by your research is engaging in reflection on what we really care about and whether we're actually living out our values. Why would this be valuable and how would it work around that?
和不能做的事情，有选择地利用这些不同的策略会非常有帮助。我确实认为在海啸的情况下，我能够在春天达到一个阶段，那时我能够行使初级控制，并做一些我希望对斯里兰卡人民有帮助的事情。所以你的研究支持的另一个做法是反思我们真正关心什么，以及我们是否真的在践行我们的价值观。为什么这会有价值，它又是如何运作的，阿兰达？
Yes, so over the last few years I've been working with colleagues on DERP and interventions to help people manage and recover from different types of adversity. And one insight that we include in our interventions, and this is taken, these are ideas that are taken from other practices like acceptance and commitment therapy. It's the idea that you know, one of the challenges when we are faced by adversity or struggle or suffering is that it prevents us, you know, dealing with the impact of that event, prevents us from living our lives the way we want to, right, or living our lives in light of the values that we care about. So one thing that we are trying to do in these interventions we're developing is to highlight for people who are taking part in this intervention the imponds of their own values, right? So despite the fact that they're going through
是的，过去几年我一直在与同事合作进行干预，以帮助人们管理和从不同类型的逆境中恢复。我们在干预措施中包含的一个见解，这些想法取自其他实践，如接纳承诺疗法（ACT）。这个想法是，你知道，当我们面对逆境、挣扎或苦难时，挑战之一是它阻止了我们，你知道，处理该事件的影响，阻止了我们按照我们想要的方式生活，或者根据我们关心的价值观生活。所以我们在开发的这些干预措施中试图做的一件事是，向参与干预的人强调他们自己价值观的重要性，对吧？所以尽管他们正在经历
challenges, despite the fact that there might be events outside the control that they're experiencing, what's imponds to them, what matters to them, and then how can they commit to behaviors that are consistent with those values? Because the idea is that even though you may be struggling or might be dealing with various challenges in the wake of adversity or in the wake of suffering, that you can somehow separate out that struggle from who you are as a person and understand that you are not purely defined by your struggles, right?
挑战，尽管他们可能正在经历他们无法控制的事件，但什么对他们重要，什么对他们有意义，然后他们如何能够致力于与这些价值观一致的行为？因为这个想法是，即使你可能正在挣扎，或者可能正在处理逆境或苦难后的各种挑战，你也可以以某种方式将那种挣扎与你作为一个人的身份分离开来，并理解你不仅仅是由你的挣扎所定义的，对吧？
That you're also someone who has values and that you can still commit to that life, despite the fact that you're simultaneously managing all these challenges that come from the immodelability. I'm struck by the fact that in some ways this is a very different model than saying trauma and adversity make us into better versions of ourselves. This is really saying trauma and adversity help us discover who we really always were on the inside. I think that's exactly right. And I think one problem with current research and post-traumatic growth is the term itself.
你也是一个拥有价值观的人，即使你同时在处理所有这些来自不可控性的挑战，你仍然可以致力于那种生活。我感到震惊的是，在某些方面，这与说创伤和逆境使我们成为更好的自己是一个非常不同的模型。这实际上是在说，创伤和逆境帮助我们发现了我们内心深处一直是谁。我认为这完全正确。我认为当前关于创伤后成长的研究的一个问题是这个术语本身。
So there are two assumptions baked into the phrase post-traumatic growth. One is that trauma is needed for you to grow, but also that you are going to become a better person. And that is a much more simplistic understanding of what happens to you when you experience a major life event that I think is the case for most people. I think it's quite likely that people can become more compassionate. They can get greater insight into their own lives. They can commit to their values again.
所以“创伤后成长”这个短语中包含了两个假设。一个是创伤是你成长的必要条件，另一个是你将成为一个更好的人。我认为，对于大多数人来说，这比你经历重大生活事件时实际发生的情况要简单得多。我认为人们很有可能变得更有同情心。他们可以对自己的人生有更深刻的洞察。他们可以再次致力于自己的价值观。
But we should be sensitive enough not to say that that means that the trauma or the adversity was worth it. You know, someone could become compassionate, someone could become wiser, someone could commit to living their values, and still experience significant challenges in their mental health or in other domains of their life. Iranda found that his own life reflected what he was finding in his research. The more he reflected on his values,
但我们应该足够敏感，不要说这意味着创伤或逆境是值得的。你知道，一个人可以变得有同情心，一个人可以变得更聪明，一个人可以致力于践行自己的价值观，但仍然在心理健康或生活的其他领域经历重大挑战。阿兰达发现他自己的生活反映了他研究中的发现。他越是反思自己的价值观，
the more he found himself connecting his own experiences growing up with those of people in other contexts. One moment of epiphany came when news broke in 2019 of attacks on two mosques in New Zealand. I end up staying up to like four or five in the morning, watching the events unfold in real time. And I had this sort of strong visceral reaction when I heard about this gunman who had gone into a mosque and was indiscriminately killing all these people. My thought was that, oh, if there was someone like that that decided to attack in North Carolina, right?
他就越发现自己将成长的经历与其他人背景下的经历联系起来。2019年新西兰两座清真寺遭到袭击的消息传出时，顿悟的时刻到来了。我最终熬夜到凌晨四五点，实时观看事件的发展。当我听说那个枪手走进清真寺并不分青红皂白地杀害所有这些人时，我有一种强烈的本能反应。我的想法是，哦，如果北卡罗来纳州也有那样的人决定发动袭击呢？
It was one of the first times where it became clear to me that my identity, being an American and immigrant of South Asian origin, who in this context could be caught up in an event like that. And I will say, looking back on that, that did mark a shift in how I started to think about myself. And my reaction to the Christ Church attack really highlighted the fact that this right, you know, this feels like something that could be done to me, right? This is something that I feel at some level, right? I felt I was been impacted by, right? Even though, like, you know, I don't have a direct connection, right? But it had this visceral sense that what was happening to them could potentially in a different world,
这是我第一次清楚地意识到我的身份，作为一个美国人，一个南亚裔移民，在这种情况下可能会卷入这样的事件。回顾过去，我不得不说，这确实标志着我开始思考自己的方式发生了转变。我对基督城袭击的反应确实突显了一个事实，即这，你知道，这感觉像是可能发生在我身上的事情，对吧？这是我在某种程度上感受到的事情，对吧？我觉得我受到了影响，对吧？尽管，你知道，我没有直接的联系，对吧？但它有一种本能的感觉，即正在发生的事情在不同的世界里，
in the different circumstances happened to me. And that's very different than your reaction to 911, which was in some extent a reaction of detachment or a reaction even of like this doesn't really affect me or this isn't about this does not concern me. Exactly. And I think you know this highlights a thing an important lesson right about how we deal with adversity, how we deal with trauma, right? So I don't doubt that the sense of detachment, the sense of normalizing trauma and adversity can be useful when you are in that context. But it also comes with costs, especially when you don't live in that context anymore.
在不同的情况下，可能会发生在我身上。这与你对9-11的反应非常不同，那在某种程度上是一种超脱的反应，甚至是一种“这对我没有真正影响”或“这与我无关”的反应。没错。我认为这突显了一个关于我们如何处理逆境、如何处理创伤的重要教训，对吧？所以我并不怀疑，当你处于那种环境中时，这种超脱感、这种将创伤和逆境正常化的感觉是有用的。但它也伴随着代价，特别是当你不再生活在那种环境中时。
And I think thinking back over my life since coming to the US, I'm struck by how, as I've gained more distance for my life in Sri Lanka, I become more aware of just how ubiquitous this normalization was. And, you know, I understand the benefits of it from a mental head perspective, but I also see the cost. There is one other domain where trauma can produce growth. Again, this growth looks very different than the what doesn't kill you makes you stronger trope. The psychologist Dean Simonton has explored the correlation between the experience of setbacks, adversity,
我想回想我来美国后的生活，我感到震惊的是，随着我与斯里兰卡生活的距离越来越远，我越来越意识到这种正常化是多么普遍。而且，你知道，我从心理健康的角度理解它的好处，但我也看到了代价。创伤可以产生增长的另一个领域。同样，这种增长看起来与“杀不死你的会让你更强大”的陈词滥调非常不同。心理学家迪恩·西蒙顿（Dean Simonton）探讨了挫折、逆境的经历，
and being an outsider, and creativity. I think the key idea here, and I think this is something that Simonton has written about, is that, to the extent to which people experience any type of unusual unexpected event that pushes people to experience the world from a non normal perspective. That sort of enables these people to sort of think about the world from the margins. And to the extent to which you experience unusual events unexpected events that enables you to sort of be open to different ways of thinking about the world and understanding human experience.
以及作为局外人与创造力之间的相关性。我认为这里的关键想法，我认为这是西蒙顿写过的内容，是人们经历任何类型的异常、意外事件的程度，会推动人们从非正常的角度体验世界。这种经历使这些人能够从边缘思考世界。而且，你经历异常事件、意外事件的程度，使你能够对思考世界的不同方式和理解人类经验保持开放。
I mean, I'm thinking about how extraordinary art often seems to emerge out of suffering. When you look at the gorgeous paintings of Vincent Van Gogh, for example, of the music of Beethoven, do you hear echoes in those artists of your own research and findings? You know, going back to this Buddhist idea, that fundamental characteristic of life is suffering, that part of what it means to be human is to find a way to confront and manage our experience of suffering and adversity. And that view I think comes out very strongly in the work of certain artists like Frida Kahlo and Vincent Van Gogh.
我的意思是，我在想非凡的艺术往往似乎源于苦难。当你看到文森特·梵高（Vincent Van Gogh）的华丽画作，或者贝多芬（Beethoven）的音乐时，你在这些艺术家身上听到了你自己研究和发现的回响吗？你知道，回到这个佛教思想，即生命的基本特征是苦难，作为人类的一部分是找到一种方法来面对和管理我们对苦难和逆境的体验。我认为这种观点在弗里达·卡罗（Frida Kahlo）和文森特·梵高等某些艺术家的作品中表现得非常强烈。
I mean I'm thinking about Beethoven who wrote some of his most famous music when he was completely deaf. That just seems extraordinary and it's a different kind of superhero trope. You know, it's not developing some new skill but really doubling down on what it is that you have inside of you. I think that's exactly right. And you know, when things then go produce great artwork, right? And you know, lived in considerable psychological pain. Frida Kahlo, produce great artwork and lived in considerable physical pain. And you know, Beethoven produced this wonderful music as he was going in death. you know, Beethoven produced this wonderful music as he was going in death. So, as an appreciative art, I might be kind of saying, well, yes, he suffered.
我的意思是，我在想贝多芬，他在完全失聪时写下了一些他最著名的音乐。这看起来太非凡了，这是一种不同类型的超级英雄比喻。你知道，这不是发展某种新技能，而是真正加倍投入你内心拥有的东西。我认为这完全正确。而且，你知道，当梵高创作出伟大的艺术作品时，你知道，他生活在相当大的心理痛苦中。弗里达·卡罗创作出伟大的艺术作品，生活在相当大的身体痛苦中。而且，你知道，贝多芬在失聪的过程中创作了这些美妙的音乐。所以，作为一名艺术鉴赏者，我可能会说，好吧，是的，他受苦了。
Many of these great artists suffered, but look what they gave us. And I think my inclination might be to focus on the artwork, right, on what was produced as a result of that experience. I think it's an interesting philosophical question, right? Whether, you know, the production of art is worth the pain and suffering, right?
许多这些伟大的艺术家都受过苦，但看看他们给了我们什么。我认为我的倾向可能是关注艺术作品，对吧，关注作为那种经历的结果而产生的东西。我认为这是一个有趣的哲学问题，对吧，艺术的产生是否值得痛苦和苦难，对吧？
I think one of the challenges we're thinking about, the changes we experience find adversity, purely in positive terms or in negative terms, I think obscures the fact that we can have a complex reaction to adversity and it can lead to positive and negative outcomes simultaneously. positive and negative outcomes simultaneously. And I think as long as we're honest about that, and we're honest about the fact that, yes, under some circumstances, people can grow more compassionate or they can increase their creativity, right?
我认为我们在思考我们经历逆境的变化时，纯粹从积极或消极的角度来看待，会掩盖这样一个事实，即我们对逆境可以有复杂的反应，它可以同时导致积极和消极的结果。而且我认为只要我们对此诚实，并且我们诚实地面对这样一个事实，即是的，在某些情况下，人们可以变得更有同情心，或者他们可以增加创造力，对吧？
But also, that is accompanied by other changes but that may not be as positive. So maybe you will continue to struggle with your mental health. Or you might experience negative changes in other domains. I think going forward, especially because the cultural narrative around post-traumatic growth is so strong, this idea, especially in the United States, and increasingly in other parts of the world,
但这也伴随着其他可能不那么积极的变化。所以也许你将继续与你的心理健康作斗争。或者你可能会在生活的其他领域经历负面变化。我认为展望未来，特别是由于围绕创伤后成长的文化叙事如此强烈，这种想法，特别是在美国，以及在世界其他地区越来越多地出现，
that bad events are an opportunity for growth. Maybe taking a slightly more humble view and saying, well, you know, adversity and trouble are bad things. You know, those events are clear events that we would not want to wish in other people. And at the same time, they can change people in different ways. And some of those changes can be positive. Some of them can be negative. And I think it's important for us to look at all those changes together before we make claims about whether someone's life is better overall compared to before the event. Miranda Joy Wichramma is a psychologist at Wake Forest University. Miranda, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
即糟糕的事件是成长的机会。也许采取一种稍微谦虚一点的观点，说，好吧，你知道，逆境和麻烦是坏事。你知道，那些事件是我们不希望发生在别人身上的明确事件。与此同时，它们可以以不同的方式改变人们。其中一些变化可能是积极的。其中一些可能是消极的。我认为在我们对某人的生活与事件发生前相比是否整体更好做出断言之前，我们有必要把所有这些变化放在一起看。阿兰达·贾亚维克拉马是维克森林大学的心理学家。阿兰达，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much for having me. What is Hidden Brain? Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes this week are Matt Ozzug,
非常感谢你的邀请。什么是《隐藏的大脑》？《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是马特·奥祖格（Matt Ozug）、
Alina Burnett, Patrick Wood and Ion Bior at NPR. In March NPR's All Things Considered Begin a Weekly Series featuring stories from our podcast My Unsung Hero. Matt, Alina, Patrick and Ion have all played an important role in making each step of that collaboration go smoothly. From the radio stories to articles with the web and social media posts, there are a lot of moving pieces in a weekly project like this, and we're so grateful for their collegiality and attention to detail. If you like our work and want to support it, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org.
阿丽娜·伯内特（Alina Burnett）、帕特里克·伍德（Patrick Wood）和伊恩·比奥尔（Ion Bior），他们来自NPR。三月，NPR的《All Things Considered》开始了一个每周系列节目，讲述来自我们播客《我的无名英雄》（My Unsung Hero）的故事。马特、阿丽娜、帕特里克和伊恩在使该合作的每一步顺利进行方面都发挥了重要作用。从广播故事到网络文章和社交媒体帖子，像这样的每周项目有很多动态部分，我们非常感谢他们的协作精神和对细节的关注。如果你喜欢我们的工作并想支持它，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。